Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata. Oggi abbiamo
deciso veramente di festeggiare questa
giornata con lo zucchero filato e
cercavo una ricetta così, carina che
permettesse di fare lo zucchero filato
senza avere però la macchina dello zucchero
filato. Ho visto quelli che impastano con
le mani sta specie di caramella
giapponese vecchia di anni e anni e alla
fine ti ritrovi questo zucchero filato
ma io volevo proprio la palla, la nuvola
Grazie alle ricerche della nostra
redazione composta da Gianmarco abbiamo
trovato un video di Projectninna che crea
a casa una macchina dello zucchero
filato. Se voi non avete i componenti e i
materiali che vi sto per presentare
sappiate che pagherete tre volte tanto
quello che paghereste comprandovi così
direttamente la macchina dello zucchero
filato
Ma chi sono io per giudicare perché
ognuno di voi potrebbe avere a casa sua
Herzo, una smerigliatrice angolare,
insomma è presente nelle case di tutti
quanti gli italiani. Serve per
smerigliare, non so nemmeno che cosa
voglia dire sinceramente smerigliare.
Gira velocissima quindi permette allo
zucchero di partire in tutte le
direzioni e quindi creare quella
specie di nuvoletta o almeno speriamo
che funzioni così. Detto ciò passiamo
subito con gli ingredienti. Per farlo
zucchero filato a casa avrete bisogno di
zucchero, una smerigliatrice angolare, il
tappo di un barattolo, una busta di
plastica. Una busta? (Chef Rico). Ah si, una bottiglia di
plastica e uno scatolone. Ma devo mettere
il grembiule secondo voi? Ce l'hai tipo (Rico)...il grembiule da meccanico? Esatto (Rico)
Mettiamo il grembiule. Oooolè. Ok. Chissà com'è venuto..una m***a!
Avevo chiesto a Gianmarco se dovevo portare
il trapano da casa e lui mi ha detto
"Ce l'avrà Pierfrancesco un trapano",  non riusciamo
ad accedere alla stanza col trapano
quindi dovremo forare questo coperchio coi denti
Potemo riscaldare la punta di un cacciavite (Mario)
Interessante il tuo punto di vista.
Scusa ma spaccalo semplicemente come si deve (Rico)
Sai come lo fai? Lo fai co questo. Ce lo infili e lo modelli su questo, lo avviti (Rico). Proviamo
Però perché non lo fa il ragazzo nel video? (Mario)
Perché aveva portato da casa una un trapano
Oddio! Non lo fate a casa, non lo fate a casa
per favore! Aspettate però mi ha dato il segno
Bravissimo! (Rico)...Madooo, ma sei già entrato? (Mario). Me lo chiedono in molti
Questo ce l'abbiamo.
Bravo, bravo (Rico e Mario). Tutti i buchini qua come
cazzarola glieli facciamo? Teoria del cacciavite riscaldatoho
O ho fatto il primo buco. Funziona? (Mario)
Eh ma questo era già un buco che stavo cercando di fare da sette ore
Più che altro mi si sfonda la mano. Non so cosa
sia questo
No, no si è piegato noo no no...ok si è aperto
Quanto è largo? Non devi andare troppo in fondo infatti (Rico)
Eh io ho il controllo poi.
Ma ti rendi conto che fai molto prima a
compratelo. Perché hai aperto sto video?...Sto
facendo dei fori enormi, potrei provare a
richiuderli dall'interno. Con un trapano era tutto più semplice (Mario)
Sei diventato pratico (Mario). Pratico un c***o! Non lo fate a casa
Tutto sto bucio di c**o, poi non so nemmeno se funziona o no...ok ho quasi finito
Direi che ci posso stare. Mazza bravissimo (Mario)
*applausi*
Sono larghi, non è una cosa positiva
Vediamo che succede invece di essere i primi a
criticarci?
Restituiamo...ci ammazzerà, ci ucciderà
e c'avrà ragione. Abbiamo dello scotch? Gianmarco
Guardalo, inquadralo
Quel coso serve per togliere i peli dei
cani. Noo non ci credo!
Eccolo, eccolo eccolo...no Gianmarco...haha è uguale (Chef Ottavio). E io a casa mia ho 27
tipi di scotch larghi così. Più che altro
perché sennò ci parte ovunque
Già i buchi so larghi. In realtà
basterebbe benissimo che uno prenda uno
scatolone più grande, però noi abbiamo
preso direttamente quello col quale era
arrivata la smerigliatrice. Se riesce
questa cosa anche se io non ho idea di
come possa riuscire. Stiamo già
sbagliando tutto. Sta prendendo forma, anche
perché tu non puoi dire che non sia lui, tu sei incastrato Gianmarco nel dover
dire che era "meglio così" sotto sotto. A
questo punto dobbiamo creare un foro che
permetta a questa smerigliatrice di
entrare dentro...Ho in mente una roba
balistica ragazzi. Questa porticina qua
ha una porticina ancora più piccola
Io ho smesso di seguire il progetto
ormai. Io taglio qui...stiamo creando un
passaggio major,
ok, poi si chiude e ha un passaggio più
piccolo solamente per il cavo. Uelà (Rico).
Ragazzi vedrete un sacco di volte Enrico qua
dentro perché sennò non so come farvelo vedere
Dobbiamo bloccare questo coso che poi inizierà a girare. Fammi vedere una cosa
Io sono terrorizzato da questa ricetta, vi giuro
preferivo quando usavo il microonde
Secondo me questa roba non regge (Rico)...non regge pure secondo me
Parte ad alta velocità (Rico)...Ma non ho finito. Ok, bravo
Funziona funziona vero? Utilizzare una bottiglia di plastica, serve per coprire la smerigliatrice
Gli facciamo un taglio verticale...
e a questo punto utilizziamo la tecnica
dell'abbraccio. Pazzesco. Direi ci può stare
Allora ok qui dicono però di fare una
cosa, staccare la spina e fare in modo
che sia settato su "on"
Non puoi accenderlo
direttamente così (Mario). Cioè ogni volta gli
devo mettere questo coso mentre gira... per rendere più vivace la (Rico)...
...più vivace la rubrica esatto. Senti questa roba qui
Giulia, che cacchio è? Effettivamente sembra diluito
con l'acqua, ma non te lo scrive? Si non sembra caramello il caramello è più denso. Dobbiamo
solamente ora fare questo composto. Ma a c***o lo dobbiamo fare questo composto?
Te lo dico subito (Mario). Fai fai a c***o, tanto tutto quanto fai a c***o alla fine (Rico)
*brusio*
Io non mi sento tranquillo. Quanto
dice? Ecco il ragazzo (Mario).
"Le proporzioni sono tre cucchiai di zucchero"...e un cucchiaio d'acqua
Ringraziamo d.b.minecraft ita, perché abbiamo
trovato delle dosi. Questo ragazzo si era
ispirato sempre allo (Mario)...allo stesso
Perfetto! Come gli è andata? Male ve? Ok, bene
Questo è il composto che vai a versare? (Rico)...Si. Fare bollire per qualche minuto (Mario)
Chef Ottavio mi sorvegli questo coso?
Ma cosa devo fare quindi? Rifacciamolo. Bisogna
buttarlo questo? Si, così poco lo bruci in un secondo
Facciamone di più. Ce l'abbiamo un bilancino per pesare? Ho visto una ricetta 250 di zucchero e 200
di acqua. Facciamo la metà? Facciamo esatto la metà.
Facciamo allora 100 e 125 anni sta
Sto versando più fuori che dentro 104...104 e 126. ! 130...come 130? 230
Noi pensiamo che Pierfra viva di solo fieno (Chef Ottavio)
Basta. Ma che è tipo zucchero di canna forse quello? (Mario)
No regà è caramello. Si chiama reazione di Maillard ragazzi (Chef Ottavio)
Reazione di Mayard? Davvero (Chef Rocco)...Certo.... Non conosci la reazione di Mayard? (Rico)...No
La reazione di maiale. Quanto manca per
l'effetto di Mayell (Rico)
Siamo arrivati alla
caramelizzazione di Meier
la famosissima, si può riconoscere come
potete vedere no? (Rico)
Mayer. Mayer proprio (Rico). Perché proprio mai! Che poi ora lo stiamo un po' facendo a occhio perché
teoricamente dovresti stare più...però le bolle iniziano a rallentare, quando le bolle iniziano a rallentare
vuol dire che so dopo i 120. Cosa dice Mayer (Rico)?...Senti
Ma vogliamo provare a versarlo così? No aspettiamo un attimo. Se è 145 è 145. Ma tu che hai
l'occhio termometro? C'è troppa acqua...deve evaporare un po'...parole della Chef.
Sono un po' più lente, sono meno frenetiche. A me sembrano uguali a prima (Rico)
Ma lo sapete comincio a sentire l'odore giusto. Qual è l'odore giusto? Scusa naso da tartufo
L'odore di acqua di Mayer
Che poi è Maillard però pazienza. Mayard? Maial? Che cos'è che
sarebbe? E' una reazione degli zuccheri al
calore...per cui si scuriscono? Dopo 140
gradi. L'odore è inconfondibile, questa è una ricetta di successo (Rico)
No l'hai detto, l'hai detto. Senti l'odore
del successo (Chef Mario)
Oddiooooo
Noooo staccalo!...Allora aspettate un secondo, Ma la consistenza c'è?Mmm...incredibile. Un po' duro alla fine
Cioè ti spacca i denti sto coso
*risata*
Devi mandarlo dentro tutto di un boccone, perché sennò diventa cemento
Allora esperimento zucchero filato
...è riuscito per metà. Questi batuffoli...quando prendi lui...è diverso quindi il consiglio secondo me
è quello che mentre lo fate, bloccate e
prendete i batuffolini e non li unite
fra di loro. 100 grammi d'acqua per 125 grammi di
zucchero, lo fate bollire finché Mayard
non trasforma lo zucchero in un
caramello che vi dico, porterà ad avere
questa consistenza. Ah sì sì sì sì sì sì (Rico)
Viene una specie di miele, lo tirerete
fuori che ancora fa le bolle però poi
automaticamente diventerà una roba pazzesca
Se lo provate a fare a casa taggatemi
sulle vostre foto di Instagram
e soprattutto fatemi capire che cos'è che
ho sbagliato e perché è uscito...
E perché è uscita la corteccia di Mayard
Ci vediamo la massima settimana con un'altra puntata. Ciao
Un altro il mio dubbio è che i fori
possano essere molto molto molto larghi
Forse facendo i fori ancora più sottili
lo zucchero esce in maniera ancora più
filamentosa. Ma secondo me la scatola è sbagliata.
Secondo me tutto è sbagliato, prendi la macchina
vai e te lo compri. Secondo me no. Calcola se usavamo un recipiente tipo di plastica tondo bucato era fatta!